- I live near Mikie Sherrill's district
and you would go to these events
and I would see these mothers I knew
from my school district.
And they were out there running
Mikie Sherrill's campaign.
I mean it really wasn't
just the women running,
it was the women running their campaigns.
Whether they were campaign
managers or volunteers.
This was really a surge
of women that we started,
you know we saw initially
with the women's marches
and it just kept going.
And I was one who thought
about the women's marches,
oh you know will this energy
really sustain itself?
And it did.
- You know, it's interesting
you say that because
I remember those women's marches
and being on the top of the roof
and watching the parade
go down the street.
And then watching the women's marches,
that whole weekend in Washington DC,
it was really supposed to
be Donald Trump's weekend
and it wasn't Donald Trump's weekend.
And my thought was, exactly as yours,
it's great that you all came
down here and they you marched
and you feel good about yourself.
But are you going to show up
when it matters to knock on doors.
And just to add to what
everyone's saying here
that this will be the first Congress
with more than 100 women
who will be serving.
Which is a record.
(applauding)
- It's a lot, and something like.